it is time to make some enemies
a little while ago a small channel on
youtube called giggup maybe you've heard
of him made a tier list of every shonen
anime it was a good video and a bold
move and seeing as depending on who's
talking i either know a lot or nothing
about dragon ball a video where i rank
every single dragon ball movie could be
interesting if nothing else quality
content for context i've been a fan of
dragon ball since i was 8 years old and
i've been covering it professionally for
about 6 years however i didn't watch
these films when i was a child and so as
a result these films were all digested
around a similar point in time except
for one or two obvious exceptions which
we will definitely be getting into if
you don't know how this works for some
reason s tier is the best of the best
and the lower the film is in the tier
list the worse the film is in my opinion
and
just so we're clear these opinions are
all objective measures of your beloved
childhood favorites and any difference
between this list and your own should be
seen as a personal attack against both
you and your family with that said let's
dive in dragon ball curse of the blood
rubies 1986.
first up in the chopping block is curse
of the blood rubies or the legend of
shenlong if you're looking at the subbed
version and while it doesn't even
approach how awful some of these later
films are it's still not really a good
watch because most of these early films
were engineered to be shown off at anime
fairs and festivals to demonstrate the
underlying themes and story beats of the
anime and manga many of the films we
discussed today will have the task of
translating themes and story beats as i
mentioned from the series into story
form or movie form and this one wasn't a
good adaptation this one pretty much
just recaps the peel off saga with minor
changes to the villain at the end and
generally had production values that
were about on par with the existing tv
show at the time it feels rushed
haphazardly cramming plot points into a
short run time all the while telling us
the story we all know and love in much
worse fashion i'm gonna put this one
tentatively in the d category it's not
quite good enough to be a c we're
starting at the bottom with a d because
dragon ball always gets that thing next
one up dragon ball sleeping princess in
devil's castle 1987 sleeping princess in
devil's castle is my editor's favorite
dragon ball movie say hi editor stan
wonderful and to be honest i can see the
appeal here sleeping princess is a
massive improvement over the first film
released only a year prior and while
there are subtle elements taken from the
original story like the set of being
roshi sending krillin and goku in search
of hot babes for training the rest of
the narrative is entirely new with
interesting looking villains and the
simple but effective story of goku and
the gang we all know and love saving the
princess in the devil's castle oh and
also the humor in this as charming as
ever with bulma's reaction to that
creepy looking old person still cracking
me up all these years later if you're a
fan of classic dragon ball and haven't
seen this one you should give it a go
all in all i think i'd give this one a c
but a strong scene
next up is dragon ball mystical
adventure from 1988. this is the final
of the three original dragon ball films
released and in my prior reviews of
these films i never formally reviewed
this one for some reason so i'm gonna do
it now because wow this one really
impressed me and once again it was a
massive step up from the previous film i
think naturally as mentioned previously
these films are required to act as
advertisements for the ongoing show and
manga and what makes this film
interesting is the difficult situation
it was in you see the prior two films
between them covered about what in a bit
arcs of the manga and at the point of
this film's release the anime was
already dealing with the demon king
piccolo stuff which meant that this
movie had to in the story take elements
from goku and krillin's training the
tenkaichi budokai the red ribbon army
saga tenshinal and chaotsu's portion of
the story as well as introduce and
incorporate characters such as pai pai
and many others and by the way all
within a short 46 minute run time and it
knocks it out of the damn park instead
of trying to cram all of these
disconnected plot elements together
haphazardly like blood rubies did or
going off and telling its own story
without covering the anime material like
princess and devil's castle did mystical
adventure somehow manages to do the
impossible and finds a happy medium
between these two philosophies instead
creating their own unique story
utilizing all of these aforementioned
plot elements in natural and creative
ways to propel the story forward this is
an utterly staggering effort to say the
least in mystical adventure chatsu is
the emperor who has lost his love suru
senen is a corrupt advisor there's a
tournament in the area and its opening
credits take care of the one major plot
point i really didn't know how they
would incorporate the training with
roshi i wasn't looking forward to
revisiting this film and out of every
movie on this list this one surprised me
the most based entirely on how impressed
i was with what i was able to achieve
given its circumstances i'm gonna give
this film a b
it's the best movie so far
now onwards to dragon ball z's first
film dead zone 1989. i'm gonna try to
pick up the pace here because we've got
like 12 dragon ball z movies to get
through and i don't expect you to sit
and watch me moan about buy our broadly
for two hours so let's do this dead zone
is a weird movie i'm happy to see that a
lot of the principles behind what made
prior films work are present in this one
also focusing on adapting the themes and
plot elements of the initial writer's
encounter garlic jr steps in for reddits
kidnaps go on and ultimately fights the
then unlikely team of goku and piccolo
presented in an entirely new story to
boot which i appreciated the designs of
the characters are sinister and fun with
some wonderful artwork that might look
familiar to those that enjoyed the
english op of the series back in the day
90s kids however while this film has all
of that working in its favor it
unfortunately kind of sucks in its
execution in trying these elements
together garlic jr wants the dragon
balls but instead of taking the dragon
ball away from gohan they just take
gohan a completely irrational decision
that obviously will lead to hijinks that
propels the plot forward totally
unbelievable and one that occurs so that
the story itself can move forward it
just feels kinda lazy and with a plot
that doesn't have a lot of elements to
tie together in the first place this is
emphasized all the more in my opinion it
has all the makings of a great film with
some terrific action and
characterization but failed in its
execution placing it firmly in the sea
tier next up is dragon ball z the
world's strongest from 1990. as
mentioned earlier in the video i pointed
out that the dragon ball films weren't
covering enough material per film to
remain consistent and up to date with
the series at large and so therefore
from this point until the end of dragon
ball z apparently toy animation would be
releasing two films per year starting
with dragon ball z's the world's
strongest where dead zone covered the
first half of the saiyan saga this one
covers the second half and while vegeta
and napa aren't present a lot of the
action and story beats in that section
are perhaps to a point where it's
somewhat distracting a lot of the final
battles take elements and set pieces
from goku's battle with vegeta with some
of them even being shot for shot
recreations however the artwork and
animation here is as iconic as early
dragon ball gets with a host of
animation cuts that you'll no doubt
remember if you watched the series's old
intro back on cartoon network in the
late 90s and early 2000s
the film's strongest moments are in the
first half for me when roshi and bulma
are kidnapped and goku has to find his
way into the base to make the save
there's a tremendous amount of character
in this film that really speaks to the
writer's involvement and understanding
of these characters i just would have
liked that the final battle did feel as
derivative as it ultimately ends up
being this movie is one hour long and i
think it might have been worthy of a
higher rank if they had shaved down some
of the exposition and created a run time
of about 40 minutes all in all right now
for me it's a c could have been a b but
yeah it's a c next up dragon ball z the
tree of might from 1990. finally we get
to the vegeta stand in for the film
universe or so to speak turlos is
effectively goku black with a gardening
obsession well okay
okay the film itself is quite solid with
some brilliant animation though the
first 15 minutes or so are quite slow
with king kai chiming in every 10
minutes to spew exposition but other
than that the rest of the film is very
enjoyable with a conclusion that ties in
nicely with the villain of the story's
mission the tree of might sucking the
life force from the earth only for the
earth's very life energy being used to
overcome the enemy is fitting if not
poetic turles himself is a fun villain
and as i mentioned the animation is some
of the best early dragon ball has to
offer once again this is a unique story
and covers the themes of the saiyan arc
nicely and what's more is that this one
also has a nice environmental message
unique to itself not bad for 1990 it's
not really exceptional enough to get
into the a tier but it's a strong
contender in the b category be tier for
this one
[Music]
today's video is brought to you by our
longtime partners over at manscape.com
they've been great supporters of this
channel for a while now and i've spoken
at length about their performance
package bundle in the past it really is
the best head-to-toe grooming kit i've
encountered and their lawnmower 4.0 is
the star of the package with its
wonderful led light and skin safe tech
the crop preserver ball deodorant is
also a pretty great part of the package
particularly in these hot months where
keeping cool and smelling great all day
is pretty damn important but what's also
essential is the follow through manscape
have released the new collection of
their anti-chafing high-performance
boxer briefs these bad boys feature a
fancy new dual pouch design a good old
bit of roomy space for your dangly bits
to breathe thanks to the perforated
performance fabric they're also now in
more than six colors combined there's a
simple all black pack or the classy grey
or pinstripe design heck there's even
this gold nugget craziness if you want
to go all out it's entirely up to you i
mean i'm not your mom whatever you
choose manscape offers the option to
select single units or save money with
their three pack options they're great
and if you go to manscape.com today and
use coupon code not mark 20 at checkout
you'll get 20 off plus free
international shipping that's not mark
20 at manscape.com your balls will thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
next up the slug movie dragon ball z
lord slug 1991
ah yes the film that revealed the super
saiyan form to the world
sort of much the same way the other
films did this one adapts material from
the mangas specifically the namic
portion from the ginyu fight with goku
showing up all the way to the eventual
reveal of the super saiyan form itself
only it didn't exactly work out the way
they wanted it to release just 10 days
before the reveal of super saiyan in the
manga this film was basically working
off design instructions from toriyama
himself that he would later further
change for practical reasons apparently
he had already decided on the hair going
up but had yet to decide on removing the
black from the hair whether you like the
way this looks or not it's kind of
interesting to see that super saiyan
could have looked like this had toriyama
decided to keep it consistent with
kaioken just with a golden aura and a
different hair shape however despite
this film having some cool action
sequences with goku fighting an
oversized lord slug the film
kinda sucks there isn't any emotional
resonance in this film and the only
discernible narrative connective tissue
comes by way of gohan's super annoying
whistling facilitating the defeat of
lord slug himself it's
not very interesting for me this is
honestly a d tier movie
dragon ball z coolers revenge 1991 this
movie definitely has interesting ideas
okay it does okay taking elements from
the cat and mouse games with the namek
saga with gohan and krillin needing to
hide their power levels this film sees
these very characters buy time for goku
who's in critical condition once again
in this film another aspect taken from
dynamic material unfortunately the
action is also pretty great my favorite
part has to be this section where
piccolo dukes it out with one of the
henchmen of cooler in the forest
sporting some really nice animation
unfortunately however the main villain
itself isn't very interesting at all in
cooler where i loved frieza cooler i
found to be excessively boring by
comparison with the eventual fight that
takes place between goku and cooler
filled to the brim with shots and
sequences taken straight out of that
very fight with frieza not helping the
comparisons themselves i'm also not the
biggest fan of goku's characterization
in this movie he's depicted as this sort
of paragon of hope and life in the world
literally resurrecting a bird from the
dead he's like this ethereal almost
divine-like figure at times in this
movie particularly towards the end
overall the film has its upsides for
sure but not enough to make me want to
come back to this anytime soon all in
all i'd put this one firmly in the sea
tier next up dragon ball z the return of
cooler 1992. this is where i think i'm
going to potentially start making some
enemies i didn't think cooler was
interesting before and certainly that
sentiment did not change in this film
for the vast majority of the runtime the
secondary cast feels utterly pointless
vegeta's showing up out of nowhere is
cool but it makes virtually no sense
whatsoever and i don't like the climax
to this film really at all but with that
said this scene where goku and vegeta
fend off the army of coolers is one of
the best shots out of any of these films
for me it's such a cool visual and what
i am sure toyotaro took inspiration from
when he was drawing this climax to the
end of the black arc in the dragon ball
super manga if you're a fan of goku and
vegeta's banter with a heavy emphasis on
mindless action this is the film for you
but i do like to have a little bit more
of a story behind it so this one just
feels too flimsy for me if it wasn't for
my love for that team up scene with
vegeta and goku i'd give this one a firm
d but it sits nicely towards the end of
the c tier for now next up dragon ball z
super android 13.
1992 i don't like this movie is what i
would say okay just kidding i really do
hate this movie it also doesn't help
that this film is about as formulaic as
it gets it's got a cold open with the
gang doing random things and suddenly
bad guys show up they fight for almost
the entire run time before goku pulls a
win out of his butt miraculously at the
end i think my favorite part of this
film is the reanimated segments of the
actual manga material a la android 17
killing dr gero towards the beginning
and now look people watch dragon ball
for a host of different reasons and i
could very well imagine a world where
one person goes into this movie and
loves it while another won't for me i
really enjoy when a good story is told
and unfortunately this film just doesn't
do that whatsoever it has virtually
nothing to say beyond a few screams and
a whole lot of punching in the dick the
flaws with this approach become clear as
day 2 at the end when due to the lack of
any emotional resonance in the story the
film's climax comes out of nowhere in an
unceremonious and in my opinion deeply
unsatisfying and cliche way with that
taken into consideration super android
13 is a solid d tier entry for me
and i wonder if the next one will be
just like that dragon ball z broly the
legendary super saiyan from 1993
believe it or not because i never
watched these films growing up broly the
legendary super saiyan was first
introduced to me through the wonderful
and endlessly talented team four star
abridged version and i loved that so i
figured i would hate the original seeing
as everyone online back in the day would
consistently moan about how much of a
meme the broly movies had become but to
be honest when i first saw this i was
pleasantly surprised although not
without its issues broly the legendary
super saiyan is full of personality and
character at least when it comes to a
few main characters when it came to
broly and somewhat with paragus i felt
as though their personalities were
secondary and their motivations totally
unimportant if not pathetic it's been
said a million times over but goku
crying in the nursery is a lame
motivation for them to fight with all of
that said the action was awesome with
some wonderful designs courtesy of
tadayoshi yamamuro who would go on to
lead the way with dragon ball super with
ironically enough dragon ball super
broly of all films being the first major
project he wasn't involved with this
film isn't revolutionary by any means or
anything approaching that but i can see
why some people love it it's got some
strong dudes with big numbers and i
think it does that pretty well it nicely
fits at the end of b-tier for me
next up dragon ball z bojack unbound
okay look i know this film is popular
with those of you that like gohan and to
be honest i too like seeing gohan at
this 8th game to kick some ass but this
film stands as a monument on how not to
write gohan as a character for me anyway
and i think that's the movie's biggest
weakness form going into this the first
time i watched i thought it was going to
be a gohan movie and it is kinda krillin
takes up a surprisingly large part of
the beginning bojack doesn't show up
until halfway through the feature and
his characterization and backstory
aren't shown to us but instead
exposition dumped onto us through king
kai rambling on
and on
and on for all of dragon ball up until
this point gohan was a passive character
that sort of let the plot happen to him
he would be reacting to things he's
reactionary this is fine if the story is
built around that but this movie wasn't
and it felt like gohan was just sort of
tagged in at the end to facilitate an
ending with the big fight which was fun
and had some cool environments to fight
in but i think for me this film just did
go on a massive disservice i think the
animation looks great but i'm just not a
big fan of this one guys particularly
the ending where goku literally comes
back from the dead through the sheer
will of wanting to or deus ex machina if
you're so bold to make the save on gohan
it's not as bad as some of the others
but it's definitely not a good film in
my estimation i think i'll be giving
this one a strong
c
dragon ball z broly second coming oh boy
here we go broly's second coming has the
single worst opening i've ever seen in
any film and with these films that's
saying something so in order for this
film to happen a series of utterly
insane coincidences have to occur
firstly broly having been punched by
goku is now flying through space and
lands coincidentally on earth of all
places covered in ice or crystal that
for some reason doesn't strip him of the
air he needs to survive also by
coincidence goten trunks and videl find
themselves standing right above broly at
this moment in time and during that
brief period goten utters the only noise
he would need to wake up him in the
first place that my friends is the level
of coincidence
we're talking about and it's absolutely
ridiculous and then videl decides to
dodge one of broly's attacks apparently
she can do that however those that love
this film do not care about all of that
and likely will only remember this
awesome fight sequence with gohan and
the eventual family kamehameha which you
know they're great moments and to be
fair are the best parts of this movie
however when you compare to the first
one you can tell that the writing and
care for the story aspects of this one
have waned considerably i mean the
shenanigans with the dragon helping goku
out at the end to just show up is one of
the dumbest and most convenient things
i've ever seen committed to the pages of
any dragon ball script but all in all
this movie is dumb and to be honest
either belongs on the border between d
tier and c tier uh i don't know editor
sign flip a coin and you can put it
wherever you want
this next one though i'm putting this
one firmly in the d category and i'm
telling you that right on the outside
this is dragon ball z biobroly i was
very mean towards biobroly in my review
of it a few years ago so let's start out
with some of the pros of this film
unlike 99 of the other films in this
video the focus isn't on goku and vegeta
which depending on your preference could
be seen as a positive and instead
focuses on the trio of goten trunks and
surprisingly you know android 18 that's
great furthermore the plot is linked
nicely to a canon event in the story
wherein android 18 is collecting the
money from mr satan for throwing the
tournament during the buu saga it's got
some relatively strong artwork and
what else um
positives
it's only 46 minutes long so you don't
have to wait long
i don't know okay look the movie is
about as bad as its reputation suggests
unfortunately despite the minor upsides
that i mentioned broly ambling around
like a dung-covered sasquatch the
atrocious pacing the lack of any
meaningful story and the fact that it's
just so damn boring stands as an
unstoppable force in the face of those
small upsides i pointed out earlier
there's not really much else to say
other than that the definition of a dpr
movie is this film unfortunately this
next one though not so much dragon ball
z fusion reborn 1995.
i think fusion reborn is often cited as
the best of the original dragon ball
movies or at least that's the impression
i got from the community around that
time a few years ago which is hilarious
when i consider that this is the film
where goten and trunks fight hitler
resurrected from the dead while goku and
vegeta fix the plumbing in otherworld
and to tell you the truth this is easily
the most rewatchable for me it's not
super long has a very simple plot with a
setup and a resolution would you believe
and has some of the best animation in
the early dragon ball films and arguably
much of the series genema's design is
cool and while taking inspiration from
majin buu has a moveset unique to
himself that remains as iconic part of
the franchise to this day with super
dragon ball heroes even making use of
him from time to time these days with
that said he's got no personality at all
and that would matter if not for the
fact that i thoroughly enjoyed the
banter between goku and vegeta in this
film it's easily the highlight for me
there's not really much else to this
film and for that i can't really give it
an s-tier ranking but i'm comfortable to
give it an a-tier it's never
disappointed me and its action is as
breathtaking in 2022 as it was in 1995.
this next one though i think has a
better story dragon ball z wrath of the
dragon this was the single most
disappointing film i've seen in this
long list of films and not because i
didn't like it i loved the movie not
just for its breathtaking visuals not
just for the incredible score but for
its emotionally rich and uniquely dark
narrative beats the relationship tapian
shares with trunks as a stoic hero from
another land dealing with an eager to
please young talent is a story that's
absolutely worth telling and absolutely
engaging and this film does an
incredible job of interweaving plot
elements from within this film and even
hints to other stories with the use of
tapion's blade being handed down to
trunks the movie is almost perfect it
has everything going for it up until
the last moment where goku literally
comes out of nowhere to totally
extinguish the emotional weight of the
film for me at the end
he had literally nothing to do with this
story and in the end is the one to take
the victory what is the significance of
that decision i ask you after having
delivered such a competent and engaging
story for it to only fumble the balls so
spectacularly at the finale causes a
level of frustration and disappointment
unrivaled by any other film in this
franchise this would be an easy s tier
but with this terrible ending i'm
tempted to put it into b tier but i'll
acquiesce and settle for an a-tier
ranking it's very frustrating that does
it for the dragon ball z films and on to
the next one which is technically a gt
film but it has nothing to do with gt
it's the gtr team reworking the original
dragon ball story in dragon ball path to
power
1996. now i'm aware that i'm about to
give a tremendous amount of praise for a
film that straight up condenses a
sizable portion of early dragon ball
into an 80 minute runtime but i am but a
simple human that loves dragon ball and
to see this early section of the story
get the love and attention it deserves
complete with spectacular animation and
art direction it's enough to make my
heart sing i
love this movie and to be honest it's
one of the only films on this list i've
since watched over and over it captures
wonderfully what those early dragon ball
chapters and arcs were like for me with
some outstanding visuals that grant life
not just the outstanding action
sequences but throughout the film even
in its quieter or more subdued moments
it's not a unique story in the slightest
but it weaves these plot points together
seamlessly and in my opinion deserves to
be in the eight tier
okay um
we're gonna talk about another uh
officially licensed dragon ball film um
dragon ball evolution 2009 this is a
film that is dragon ball in name only
none of the characterization is correct
none of the themes tackled are remotely
connected or tied to the original story
and the script of the film itself was
panned so harshly online that the writer
actually apologized to the online masses
sighting that he was at that point in
his career just in a place that he
needed the money i'm making a new tier
for this one below d i'm gonna call it
tier e the e isn't for evolution it's
for excretion because this film is utter
[ __ ] and now we finally arrive at the
modern dragon ball material and it's
time to kick things off in style with
2013's battle of gods having just
created a new rank for the worst dragon
ball film ever made we make our way to
arguably the best when the announcement
came that dragon ball was coming back
with a canonical addition to the story
in this film my excitement went through
the roof and when it came out i was not
disappointed this feels like dragon ball
in every sense of the word and more than
anything else also had the benefit of
toriyama's direct involvement it has
some superb animation spectacular
characterization introduces a host of
new characters that become incredibly
important moving forward in the story
and expanded the scope of what was
possible for dragon ball to never before
seen heights it's funny it's charming
it's action-packed and it's a wonderful
ending it's everything i want in a
dragon ball film battle of gods is an
easy s-tier film for me i wish i could
say the same for resurrection f in 2015.
unlike battle of gods i had a lot of
problems with this movie not the least
of which was it feeling as though it was
retreading over already done material in
an effort to make a quick cash grab
surprisingly the super anime does some
brilliant stuff with frieza later in its
run but this film not so much this film
is also almost entirely fighting with
the majority of said fighting boring me
half to death couple that with the
ending and you have for yourself a very
unsatisfying film in hindsight it's way
better than whatever the hell that
adaptation in super was but it's still
not nearly as good as battle of gods for
me it's between c and b tier but i'll
put it in b tier for now
next up dragon ball super broly 2018.
some people love this movie and others
not so much there's a wide range of
opinions on this film but for me i
honestly really liked it i think it
easily has the best soundtrack of any
dragon ball film that i've seen it
manages to characterize and humanize a
character that was lacking in both of
those departments desperately turning
him into a truly interesting character
the animation is quite literally the
best dragon ball has ever seen and the
story has some interesting moments
throughout for me i love goku and
vegeta's dynamic and frieza is
brilliantly devious in this one too it's
also a funny movie whilst not utilizing
a lot of humor the pockets or moments it
steals away to do something quirky or
funny are always enjoyable i've gone on
the record and said that i wasn't a fan
of dragon ball minus but even that
material in this film hits in a much
more satisfying way than the comic did
additionally this movie focuses a lot on
action which depending on what you want
or might be looking for is a good or a
bad thing for me i think the action goes
on a smidge too long and i think if they
had developed or expanded more beyond
the fight itself it could have made this
movie much more enjoyable for me with
that said i think those are small gripes
and my enjoyment experience while
watching this film cannot be understated
i think out of all the dragon ball
movies i've watched this one the most
the highs are extremely high but it does
have its flaws in my opinion i want to
put this in s tier but it just falls
short for me the animation and action is
absolutely ester but overall i'm
thinking of putting this movie maybe at
the top of a tier and finally that
brings us to
2022 with dragon ball super super hero
my formal review of this film will
eventually come out once the film is
released digitally for all of us to see
and so right now i can't make a formal
decision on where i would rank it but i
do have friends that have seen the film
and so for the purposes of this review i
have asked them to share with me their
thoughts on the film with a rank and the
overall rank reached by these guys was
estier although one of them did make
sure to point out that it wasn't as good
as battle of gods with them having some
minor issues with it however those
issues couldn't have made that much of a
difference as this film still comes away
with the s-tier ranking and for that
reason among many others i'm excited to
review this film later this year and so
that's the video everyone i hope you all
had fun i think i might do something
less controversial next week like
ranking all the one piece acts or
something but until then i've been
totally not mark and thank you all so
much for watching
[Music]
you